[Music]
welcome back to just kidding news where
we talk about
whatever you want and the format is you
did it so
it was the record oh he did it different
new intro what do you think that okay i
like it i like it i like the new
new tradition is born yes
what the [ __ ] got that in mexico it's a
jaguar now it's 50
better
[Applause]
it does sound like a [ __ ] wild cat do
you play that when you're naked
yep and just a hat on because it's a
sunny day are you spinning your dick
around while you're doing it yeah
okay helicopter ticket yeah
can you guys do that oh yeah yeah oh
yeah well he's got a long dick
according to you look you got it you got
a real a real cycle if it's
if it's hard it's just this way i can't
do the model it has to be soft
can you show me what the hip has to look
like in order to get a full circle
the hip you she's just
uh trying to see what you're working
with and you're failing right now
she didn't like it i'm not feeling that
horny yet i got to be in the mood it's
hotter because he he's unavailable isn't
it it is it is for sure
yeah that's his move oh [ __ ] so we're
gonna talk about you guys [ __ ] the
whole time
here we go 20 minutes let's go why did i
miss that is that what happened on that
last episode
she's 60 wants to have sex with joe and
i said i'm 100
then i asked you let's do it and then
you said i can't so it's not really i
think you're actually forty percent and
to catch you up
yeah you should get more confident to
catch you up uh something that's super
cool that i was like oh shit's
interesting is
her and jared have an open relationship
even though
they're married and have kids i know i
want to wrap my brain around it
but she never acted out on it so then
it's the option is optimal open
yeah oh yeah it's like an open sandwich
but then
she got the bread and closed it anyway
and
like an open floor plan and she filled
it up with furniture exactly
or those like dividers that you put up
oh yeah exactly
what it is the point yeah the point is i
mentally feel like i have the option and
that makes it fun
it's like an open house with a locked
door but
you could still invite people over and
they just don't know until they get to
the front door that they just
actually can't come in right you can
invite them which is the fun
you just weren't home you were on
vacation what
do you think would happen in a scenario
where you started [ __ ] somebody else
but then you guys keep on [ __ ] and
like that goes that goes on for months
and months
and like maybe like i fall in love with
that person catch feelings you don't
know
well i mean that there's an i that's an
option right i guess that's like you
know if you have a friend
you have a bet you guys have a best
friend right and then he moved to vegas
he can meet a new friend and hang out
with their friend all the time and then
now your position is at risk but
we're not really jealous like that
though yeah i feel like
you're p people are capable of loving
many people yeah
so it's it's i don't know it doesn't
feel
weird that if it happens i just be sad
because i thought i thought i was the
only one if bart has a new best friend
let's not tell him
yeah don't tell him don't break it don't
tell me anything i don't want to know i
don't think i can barely
make this whole bad friendship you guys
are best friends
how long have you been number one best
friends for indisputable number ones
i don't even know i think we [ __ ] around
with that title but it's just by default
yeah just because we started the company
together yeah or like we just spent a
lot of time
are you guys actually this number one i
guess so it's kind of gay yeah what are
you what do you think
no it's not like what do you mean like
what what defines best friend
to you my it's like your partner he's
the he's the guy
he's the guy that i trust the most and
you like hanging out with the most your
favorite i like you now with joe yeah
the most no bart's real best friend is
geo yeah i'm not trying to break him up
i'm trying to
bart's real best friend is geo my my
real best friend is geoffrey i'm his
number one male friend but outside
outside of geo joe's my best friend yeah
i think the trust thing is pretty big
though because that's like i mean you
can enjoy hanging out with certain
people now like i like having you know
going out and hanging
but to trust them with like secrets or
like super important like dangerous
things it's like yeah that's that's
yeah like if i was gonna go climb a
mountain i'd probably want to go with
david to watch him scream the whole time
because that's funnier
yeah but if you need to make it to the
top yeah can you follow me
if i have anything that i need to talk
about or i need to like bounce something
some real [ __ ] some real [ __ ] it's going
to be
joe i think i asked the question last
time if you killed somebody who would
you go to help you cover up the murder
part
you go to bart i'll [ __ ] you i go to
bart in a second i said not bart anymore
not bart anymore because he has a family
to take care of if it was single bar i'd
go for bar
i appreciate it but i will go for a guy
who's dispensable oh [ __ ] wow what an
honor for that guy
he's like really i'm your friend that
you go to if you killed somebody cool
man he's like yeah he's dispensable
that that is smart that's like the
beginning of joker right you have the
last person
get the money and then boom and then
take the money
right that question is like why would i
want to ruin my
friend's life who has a lot to live for
not about it too hard bro
i have to ruin my friend's life who has
nothing to lift
not if they're good at it not if they're
good at hiding well i don't know i don't
know enough about but apparently
everybody else he comes highly
recommended
that he takes care of that if you need
somebody who's going to focus on a plan
there's your guy but you'll have to
schedule it with them because if someone
dies today
so you have to preserve the body because
he's not available for two weeks
and you're like oh please bart come
through dude he's like sorry i'm in
vegas right now i can't
too many assassinations i'm overbooked
my next disaster's open is in november
no bart's the [ __ ] cuz he's a [ __ ]
volt
he is down as [ __ ] there's no thing
that's too hard for him to do he has so
many tools
like he can like run for like he's
athletic he knows how to [ __ ]
commit crimes
he's good you're breaking the hell he
could break into house why do you call
him a volt though because i think of a
chevy volt which only goes like 80 miles
and then it runs out uh because you did
like whatever you tell him it stays
there
vault oh vault i heard vault 2 and i was
thinking like i wasn't gonna say nothing
i was like is that like a tennessee
football team
the tennessee vault okay yeah i can see
it i like how you played along with it
though you're like yeah i could
see that practical easy on the
environment
you just have to schedule it is what it
is yeah hey bart i'm in a pickle all
right dude
you got september third at three o'clock
i got you
and i'm like all right dude it's
guaranteed july 27th
let's do it she better hope that the
cops don't find his google calendar
because they're
gonna be like oh yeah like five murders
happened to this one
we got a clear account he's probably
sitting there 30 minutes early yeah
you got you got to come same time you
got to call me if i say
i close at 10 my kitchen actually closed
at night
and it has to be before 10 because he
gets really sleepy by nine times he
can't cook at night what's the sex
schedule then
is he is he showing up and he's sitting
there naked 30 minutes early
already with all the lights out in the
room just saying that he sounds kind of
hot
very practical because he has to take a
shower because then right after that he
wants to go right to sleep so yes he'll
have his teeth brushed
he'll have a shower so everything's very
clean gentlemen you say
yeah you know um but it has to be before
10 o'clock anything after that i'm
like i'm [ __ ] in not the good way i
just pictured him on the bed waiting for
you
with the towel over here looking at
nothing
just waiting does she run like 9 45 now
the kitchen's closed
close i [ __ ] told you you should have
had your orders in earlier you could've
called it it's like 9 35 then that's
it i've lost him we're not having and
he's like i'm coming at 9 41 and then
i'm
that's it i used to understand you get
about two pumps left
i get it yeah that's i mean that's what
i said you started a little too late
you're gonna get 10 less pumps today
yeah i do have some weird biological
shutdown like even when i'm laying in
bed like let's say scrolling on my phone
she knows i'm falling asleep because
that's when i just start dropping the
phone myself
they just have that it just starts
tapping at like 10 for some reason i've
done this so many times
where i just [ __ ] god damn it and
then i'm awake for another hour because
i hit myself in the head with a [ __ ]
five pound phone yeah
yeah the phones don't get smaller either
they keep going you guys do this by the
time it's an ipad
why don't you watch it like i do i do
that but then my hand falls asleep so i
go like that yeah i just started i just
knocked out you're watching
it like this i dropped my phone in my
own head so many [ __ ] times a week
it's insane every time it's a
disappointment
because you're like i'm an idiot i'm
like if i could see the angle of this
i'd be like
that guy's a [ __ ] it's oh it's me
there's no other way though because that
didn't look comfortable at all
the way that joe had it's like why don't
you watch it like this yeah no i watch
it like this
like this so like i've got a crick in my
neck i don't know [ __ ] why
no this works no use your shoulder as a
pillow no
joe always looks uncomfortable though
but he's not moving
very comfortable so what's been the
funnest thing
of complete [ __ ] subject change
because i saw your hair what's been the
funnest [ __ ] about having long hair
the fun is [ __ ] yeah that i don't have
to take care of it i didn't realize it
was so easy
but you know i've been bald for like
five ten years of my life right
i haven't had a haircut since uh last
year may my barber keeps asking about
only a year and three months of hair
growth he grows it yeah he grows it was
a fast
and it used to be it used to be like
that yeah yeah yeah it made
sure you had a little bit longer in the
middle you had a little poofy poof but
yeah
yeah that's amazing and so you like that
is it does it get hot or
it's easy man what about around your
ears because that's my thing if it gets
around my ears i [ __ ] this
um so like this is pretty comfortable
and then it looks nice yeah and then if
it's like all over the place
then it's like i'm about to eat some
[ __ ] okay let's go oh so you and the
girl both put chairs up
yup that's cute and then uh we both use
this as a handlebar
and then when you 69 you go
she's back i'm back i never left she
never left
today's video is brought to you by
upstar
imagine it's the end of the month you
get your credit card statement in your
email
oh no anxiety your heart's pumping
because you don't have any more money to
pay for all this stuff
you look at it anybody in college knows
this feeling
because i am still traumatized till this
day and it's been almost 20 years later
and i'm i do not like credit card bills
i don't like bills in general
but upstart can help you on your path to
financial freedom
upstart is a fast and easy way to pay
off your loan
really quickly and easily all online so
there's people
that are consolidating all their credit
card debt or they're paying off their
loans
or if they have personal expenses
there's over half a million people that
have already used
upstart to benefit their financial
situation and the cool part is
they know that like you're more than
just your credit score
so they take into consideration if you
have a job
and all these other factors to see if
you're good
to loan and the cool thing is it only
takes about five
minutes to get your check online to see
if you're approved
and you could get it the next business
day and the amount can range anywhere
from a thousand to fifty thousand
dollars
that's a so find out if upstart can
lower your monthly payments today by
going to upstart.com
off the record that's upstart.com
off the record and don't forget to use
our url so they know that
we sent you and loan amounts will be
determined by your credit your income
and other certain information that you
put on your loan application make sure
you go to upstart.com
off the record do you do the do the man
bun
no i can't i don't know i thought you
did for this one i could have sworn i
edited a couple videos no no you got to
do it just a little like how mine is up
here oh i don't know how to do that
you just just move it okay is that a man
bun or is it a carrot top oh my god
whatever you want it to be you could
have told us about the long hair stuff
by the way
oh i mean i just don't know what guy
perspective right because for me i like
i've always had long hair yeah and i've
never been bald the difference for guy
or like for me at least what surprised
me was the
after shower how long it takes to
freaking you have a lot of hair like me
yeah it takes a while and then you go to
sleep with a [ __ ] wet ass head
do you ever have it like where it like
gets [ __ ] like weird when you wake up
because your hair was wet when you go to
sleep
because mine used to do that like when i
had like shoulder length there it would
like poof up on the side
well you had long hair too in high
school i grew my hair out to like yeah
[Laughter]
we have an inflatable jacuzzi in our
backyard as you know um
and following she was telling me like
the next day she was like
she's like my hair's still wet from the
jacuzzi last night and i'm like
don't tell me everything why what's
wrong with that that's that sounds like
um that sounds like [ __ ]
something's growing in there now no but
she she conditions the pool though
with the chlorine you guys share poop
conversations no you don't do anything
they don't even share a bathroom okay
that's a real high bar
of don't tell me everything don't tell
me everything i don't even consider her
my friend frankly yeah
but i kind of mean that in a way where i
don't [ __ ] my friends
you know what i'm saying right i have
standards well i mean some people have
the theory that you're supposed to marry
your best friend so
you would [ __ ] your friend but he's not
a friend [ __ ] they're friend [ __ ]
see those people are friend [ __ ] i'm
a friend [ __ ] i'm sorry
i'm not a friend [ __ ] i mean that
actually i think that makes me less
dangerous because i don't [ __ ] friends
so see yeah that makes sense oh yeah
more dangerous to me
what does that mean like bart's [ __ ]
his friend zoned geo
yeah they're friends they're friends
it's funny they friend-zoned each other
and [ __ ] each other i think it's
[ __ ] up but then if you meet somebody
who he's like you should she's just a
friend
you got to be like where where oh i mean
i've seen him flirt i think i'm fine
i think i'm good yeah we workshopped it
a couple times today it was really bad
news
it was rough i'm not i don't feel
threatened when you see him
so going back to open relationship when
you see him flirt what does that do to
you he doesn't flirt though that's the
thing
you just said you saw him played a
little oh no he was talking about me it
was a role play
yeah we had a role play earlier today
and well even him flirting with me
it's good stuff it's uh it's it's we can
work on it you know what i mean i think
flirting with your partner is harder
than flirting with someone doesn't know
you
because your partner knows you and
you're like [ __ ] [ __ ] you're being
weird right now
somebody who doesn't know you well i
mean if we're in the mood
like if we're in the middle of sex i'm
all about flirting like i love that [ __ ]
but then it just gets
like i don't know he gets like uh i
don't know he gets funny he gets too
funny
he gets too funny isn't he too funny i'm
on fire all the jokes you coming out
i'm in the zone babe i can't stop start
work shopping the stand-up set in the
middle of it
yeah yeah i'm like dave chappelle dude
he's [ __ ] just crushing it do you
guys like to see other people flirt with
each other
i mean other people flirt with your
partner i think we hate well i can't
speak for myself i hate people so much
that i don't even consider other people
i hate people so
much just to say he's out and you you
and tech are in the car
he goes out to popeyes
and you can tell that the counter lady
is all like he's so oblivious
are you do you get turned on by the fact
that other people are turned on
by your partner i don't even see it i
don't even
i don't even see that you don't see that
people are giggly around bart no
because you're like how can you like
this disgusting man are you [ __ ]
crazy no i don't i just don't even think
my mind goes there
walks around topless last time i came in
you were topless upon arrival
and i was like are you gonna shoot the
show like this yeah
yeah he does sometimes
yeah i don't think about i wonder why
yeah i don't think about that
when you're having sex you don't ever
picture
him with somebody else while you're with
him no
wow i do that all you picture your dude
with somebody else while you're [ __ ]
hi
yes well you're bi right
no okay i could be i'm a try bye i've
never
actually had sex with a woman before i
can picture
the person i'm with with another woman
but never with another man
oh okay sometimes in a sea of women
where i can't even fit the bed and they
kick me off and say you watch oh
[ __ ] you watch him cry yeah watch and
cry and i'm just there
petting the dog just [ __ ] dog that's all
i gotta
this is boring and then he turns and he
kisses the dog
no we can't we'll do it on patreon yeah
yeah i never think that i wonder why
does anyone else have anything about
this think about my wife with other
people
i will [ __ ] rage bro but that could
be that could make the sex better in
theory
i'll try i'll try it i think he's just
thinking about not busting because he's
a [ __ ]
he's busy
[Laughter]
oh yeah you know it he's practicing his
material on geo
he's got his [ __ ] like flash cards
that's the only moment he workshops his
jokes
before i actually had sex with nikki we
used to be friends first
but if you are a friend you are a friend
foreign back okay so we were friends we
were part of a sketch
troupe for a long time okay and then we
she used to joke about how she was very
funny in bed
and so that was always like shtick that
she was really funny and she's flirting
and then yeah well i didn't realize it
at the time and then i [ __ ] her and i
was like that wasn't very funny at all
you were like disappointed you were just
like where the [ __ ] were the jokes
there was so i'm not even kidding there
was so much build up about how funny she
was in bed
and then i was like that didn't even do
one joke or nothing you're coming to
break up with it for life
yeah no premises freaking false
advertisement dude i know
so what was that supposed to be funny
that she kept pitching well you know how
there's
that thing that happens sometimes with
couples where there's too much jokes
during sex yeah all the time
that can really [ __ ] with [ __ ] and we
were bitching about that i think when
she came up with that she's really funny
in bed and so then she just wrote that
joke
yeah and so we all thought that she was
really funny in bed
but she was just gaming us uh who's we
oh me us the guys in the troops
oh yeah me and the wrestling boys is she
very sexy in bed
oh [ __ ] yeah she's a smoke show dude
it's crazy smoke show
i haven't heard that in the world she is
dude she's great but yeah
uh it was i was just disappointed by the
humor level though did you see how to
work on her material did you give her
notes
no
i think the guy who doesn't want to know
that her hair was wet after going in a
hot tub
doesn't want jokes in the bedroom sounds
like a pure romance kind of guy
with a friend how dare you it is true
though i
i love my wife it's fun it's all good
are you and jared that comfortable where
it's like you guys can have a
conversation while someone's taking a
[ __ ] oh a thousand i mean
i am that comfortable i find like every
part of him i literally this is
something i'll say because it's minute
18 right now because he gets so mad if i
said this but
like sometimes i'll say to him like i
love you
i will eat your poo like there's nothing
gross to me he's like stop [ __ ]
saying that but like it bothers him but
i'm like i will eat your poo
would you really like how much there's
nothing gross about him to me
he's going to open a toilet one day and
you're like i told you so
would you really
and then he really pooed one and he said
put this in your mouth you would put the
poo in your mouth i would
wow i would do it
i didn't think i could love you anymore
which is the fetish of having people poo
i don't have that fetish
i wouldn't want to eat his poo but in
theory yeah
nothing gross nothing gross about him to
me yeah yeah i would guess that his
poop's pretty gross though
of anything you don't know what you're
talking if i had to guess though because
i don't know
you don't know him yeah i don't know his
diet but
yes not so good
that's beautiful i love that would you
eat each other's poop he'd probably eat
my poo for sure
[Music]
he might pick it up with his bare hands
yeah no i can't do it i'm not a fan of
it
i can't no joyful eat but yeah
it's a beautiful eat it's like can't be
any worse than ever he's like
yeah i don't know during sex though like
whatever would get him off i think i
would
i would for sure try to go in that
direction yes like [ __ ] on your chest
uh if if i saw how much it turned him on
like i
you're not in the same like logical
brain you know what i mean so it's just
like let's [ __ ] try it at the end of
it when i come back to
it i got
[ __ ]
yeah why didn't you come after i
swallowed it
yeah i'd mortified like bart standing
over you with poo come all over you
and he's like yeah
there's no guilt after he comes either
he's just he just goes
oh i'm playing for my meeting oh man
it's 9 59.
[Music]
you